so you've started your youtube channel
but it's not making any money yet well
in this video we're gonna share with you
five ways to get started making money on
youtube
right now and if you're just joining us
for the first time
or you've been watching or listening to
the podcast my name is heather torres
and i
am your host of the think marketing
podcast i want to welcome you to today's
episode
and if you're new here we do a new
podcast
uploaded every single tuesday just for
you talking all things to do
with youtube and growing your online
business
now we are in a four-part series this is
video or podcast number four of this
series
where we're breaking down the way to
start on youtube
we want to help you build a highly
impactful and highly profitable
youtube channel and so we've been
breaking down through the last three
episodes
the four pillars to do this now pillar
number one
was to claim and master your topic
pillar number two
is to know your audience's problems
and ambitions pillar number three was to
upload a significant video one time per
week and then
number four is what we're getting into
today all about making money on
youtube we're talking about the shortest
path
to revenue that's key the shortest path
to revenue we're going to be breaking
down
through sean's illustration of his
journey how to actually
make money on youtube it may not be how
you actually think and so we're going to
be breaking that down
in these five different steps for you in
this episode now
we want to encourage you to share this
with a friend if you know someone who's
struggling to make money on youtube
and get the word out so that they know
how to do this as well
and to also let you know that this
episode is brought to you by our think
master class i'll tell you more about
that after this episode
and let you in on an opportunity to join
us for a free class
all about how to win on youtube well
let's jump into today's featured
conversation
with sean cannell
so we've walked through claiming and
mastering your topic
understanding your audience's problems
and ambition posting
one significant video per week and now
sean we're gonna be diving into probably
your favorite topic
and we're going to get into your story
but it's the shortest path to revenue
and i say it's your favorite topic
because
this topic is what allowed you to become
financially free it's allowed you to be
at home with your wife and your child
it is what has funded the mission for
what you want to do here at think and so
i'm excited to get into these
five ways that you could make money
right now and i want to tell the think
marketing listeners that these might be
ways that you've heard before
but this uh this conversation we're
gonna dive deeper into the
story behind them why we chose them and
how you can start implementing them this
year on your channel and so
these aren't a secret these are probably
ones that you've heard before
like i just said but i'm excited because
we're gonna jump into
your journey sean so number one uh which
is the shortest path
is uh focusing on your day job to fund
your dream job and i want to start with
just kind of your background
because maybe someone right now is brand
new to think and i'd love for you to
give some details
and jump into number one yeah you know
when it comes to making money on youtube
this might seem
not like we're dodging the question but
the truth is when you upload that first
video on that first day and you only get
one view
or no views and you have no subscribers
we're not going to make any money that
day
so when i think about the shortest path
to making money on youtube
it's actually probably going to be
getting money from somewhere else
off of youtube to fund your youtube
dream
and that's what i did you know i started
to capture vision for the potential of
youtube i think that's key
think about when you have 10 000
subscribers a hundred thousand think
about
when you've got hundreds coming in a
month thousands a month even when
there's none coming in a month and then
invest in that that's the reason you
start any business that's the reason you
start any you join a network marketing
company
you ride share you have a vision for the
future i had a vision for what i wanted
to have
happen on youtube but at the time i was
working
at red robin i was waiting tables i was
part-time at my church in our small town
called marysville
washington an hour north of seattle and
i was using my
day job now my spouse was also working
as well sonia
had three different jobs she was waiting
tables at a place called ivers and
michael teo
she was a barista at starbucks and she
was also
a nanny for our friends tj and kevin so
we're working all kinds of different
streams of income and we're using that
to pay our bills
but we were also using that eventually
to invest
in youtube in 2009 i started a media
company called clearvision media which
was just really me freelancing
and i actually took out a loan to start
it but the way i was going to pay down
the loan i went to prosper.com
to take out a loan so i could buy a
camera and buy a
computer was i thought okay if i don't
make any money from freelance work or
from youtube or from this side hustle
then i will pay it off with tips from
red robin and from working at my day job
so again and i think a lot of people are
in this situat this situation listening
to this
but this is the thing to get the money
somewhere else focus
on your day job to fund your dream job
and think about how you can maybe
streamline that
you know i was willing to really work
hard
for the dreams that i've had so i worked
three days at red robin thursday friday
and saturday busiest days of the week
and i did what was called doubles that
means you work the am shift and the pm
shift so i was able to work about 32 34
hours in three days
i was definitely crushing you know rock
stars red bulls in those days it was
wireds
their you know wired energy drink and
you know young guy
i'm working and i'm making tips and i'm
making uh hourly which kind of becomes a
watch watch when you're a waiter
but all to say was i used three days a
week so that i could work part time at
my church so that i could work on my
side hustle
the other four days a week by
structuring
if you will your day job your main way
of making money
so that you could be chipping away at
your dream job with
the way you're managing your calendar
and your time yeah and i think about
this
you know i come from the different side
of it being
a stay-at-home mom at one point and what
that looks like so if you're thinking
how do i focus on my day job to find my
dream job when maybe you don't currently
have a job
i love how you said you can really start
to just invest maybe
you're uh nannying like sonia did or
there's other ways that you can start to
fund those things right because
youtube isn't youtube the platform is
free but
you do need to actually use some money
to invest in the right tools or invest
in the right software
so i'm excited to get into uh number two
which is to start
a side hustle and that really can be the
next catalyst
into the shortest path to revenue yeah
and so this was my path
and this kind of i touched on it in
point number one but by starting a side
hustle
i'm really encouraging you to start your
own
business now at this point maybe you're
listening you think i've already done
that or we talk at think marketing
we say you're a business owner when you
start a youtube channel you need to
think like a business owner
even as even a youtube creator or you're
already an entrepreneur you already have
a business
and you want to market that business or
extend your influence on youtube or
create a whole other side
of income and so again that's what i did
i
started a side hustle i knew i wanted to
be a youtube creator so
i was getting video cameras computers
editing software but then also selling
my
video services at the time so i was
tying my side hustle
and relating it to the eventual of
business that i wanted to build
in the future and this was just assuming
you need some extra money because
you want to think about your youtube
channel like a startup that you would
invest in how much would it cost to open
up a local
coffee shop in your city you're going to
lease some
you know office space or restaurant
space you're going to
lease potentially or purchase very
expensive
espresso making machines and coffee
machines beans if you're going to roast
you get that's going to be a whole
nother thing
you're going to pay employees up front
you're going to pay a lot to open up a
brick and mortar
just coffee shop to the tune of 50 000
100 000 it could be a quarter million
dollars
you're going to take out lines of credit
if you're going to start a youtube bit
this is what's so cool about the fact
that we can
enter into the space of making money
online making money on youtube
it is such a low-cost low-risk
investment
even if you invest in some education you
know like some kind of training or an
online course even if you buy a camera
even really expensive cameras like if
you spend
ten thousand dollars on your side hustle
on youtube
you could get you got the best software
best cameras best training best
you'd have a lot of stuff happening for
you and that is a drop in the bucket
compared
to what you would pay to potentially
start a different type of business
so again we're talking about money for
the mission and what you're going to do
to the coffee example is you're also
probably not going to be profitable
in any kind of business you start for
two to three years
and so if you open up that coffee shop
that's why you have lines of credit
you've spent maybe that quarter million
dollars investing employees ahead of
time you're not showing profit
not on the first month not in the first
year maybe not in the first two
to three years now the cool thing again
following our strategies
maybe you have a viral video maybe
things happen quicker for you
but the reason i want to really hit this
start a side hustle
is find a way to make extra money to
fund the bigger brand or bigger business
that you want to build and so for me
that happened to be because i was so
good at video
doing clear vision media my media
business but this could be real estate
like steve panetta wanted to start
growing on youtube and other video
platforms
when he joined video ranking academy but
he already had a successful
real estate business so he was talking
about injecting more
um you know traffic and awareness into
his existing business
it could be network marketing you know
tara did essential oils
um and doterra she ranks some videos for
doterra so she already has a vehicle
to make money her own business a network
marketing company doterra
that's her side hustle or her main
hustle and youtube is then
more traffic injected into that but even
if you don't have youtube traffic yet
you can still
pound the pavement call somebody talk to
your friends get your cousins
do whatever it can to build your
business outside of just
opening uh you know uploading a video
posting and praying
hope is not a strategy just hoping that
video breaks out
so um think about your side hustle
and it could also be things like you
might want to do ride share or
maybe you freelance your services like
if you can do admin work
like if your dreams to work from home
maybe you can upload your services on
upwork.com and you become your own
va you edit videos for somebody you
transcribe videos
you do all of the different services
graphic design
um you you do what's your sales on the
phone a lot of things you could do from
home
finding a way to fund your dream job why
you have a day job
yeah and i that last point that you make
i think was a really
good spotlight it's the idea that
working towards where you want to go
right so when you think about the
one-off jobs that you did they were very
much related to the things you're
teaching now
right and i love the idea of you know
really evaluating
back in number one which is claim and
master your topic
what are you passionate about what could
you right now just start helping a
business with and i
was kind of in that similar similar
realm i was
helping different small businesses just
post on
facebook you know it wasn't a huge i
wasn't getting a large
salary i was getting a couple hundred
dollars a month that was then going
towards
what i knew i wanted my future to be so
i love that idea about starting
a side business now we are not lawyers
we are not tax attorneys we're none of
those things
but i think it is more so rather than
get going out like yes you need this llc
or you need an s corp whatever that
stuff is
definitely research those things but
it's the mindset
right it's coming in with the mindset of
a business owner i think
when you treat youtube like a hobby it
will
give you dividends like a hobby a hobby
is something you
spend money on you don't normally make
money back from it right it's an
enjoyment it's an entertainment
but when you have a business and you're
focused on
business and you look at youtube even if
it's five hours a week like we just saw
in the last episode
you can start seeing income when you're
correlating those
other things to this youtube channel so
i love that
idea of ride sharing that could be part
of your
youtube business right because you are
looking at it as a holistic approach to
what you are doing love that yeah and
you know
where this really gets exciting and
we've never taught this anywhere before
i think in this exact way but this also
when you streamline everything gives you
the opportunity for this
your goal should be to master the topic
do the thing and then teach on the topic
teach the thing and so look at how this
works because i started clear vision
media
i knew that also on youtube i was i had
a video production business but then on
youtube i was also teaching people about
video production and doing affiliate
marketing related to cameras
when i think about nicole from kids ot
help she was actually doing kids
occupational therapy
client coaching or client work or even
with a day job
and then teaching as she's sharpening
her skill
in that arena teaching that on youtube
now able to do it full time
you take somebody like ben again living
in the world of learning about he was a
personal trainer
and now he teaches ketosis and things
like that so when possible
if you can make your side hustle
connected to your youtube channel talk
about rideshare
there's a blog that i know about it's
called the rideshare guy so he continues
to do rideshare why so he's in the
trenches
getting video ideas getting examples and
then how's he make money
he you get affiliate credit when people
sign up for uber lyft is drivers
you get credit for helping people with
the best gps or affiliate marketing to
fixing their car or car loans like a
million things
because you're actually in the trenches
doing the thing
when you're tulan's another example of
one of our video record academy students
from
a while ago she's one of the top
beachbody
coaches she was a plus size fitness
coach kind of a niche she carved out
100 000 subscribers on youtube and
she is doing the thing by actually doing
the beachbody workouts
helping people helping people in her
downline on her team etc
and then also teaching about that on
youtube it only makes your content
sharper
and that was my vision as i saw ahead i
was like i'm gonna grow my affiliate
income grow my youtube ads as long as it
takes
but in the meantime i'm gonna be in the
trenches doing freelance work through
clear vision media
wherever my jobs take me for a while i
was a director of communications at a
church
and i was trying to synergize every
aspect of my life because i was
learning all of the very skills all the
very case studies
getting the depth that i believe makes
this think marketing podcast strong that
makes our content strong that makes our
courses strong
because i wasn't trying to just go
straight to youtube i had
a foot in the trenches of my topic being
totally immersed
and earning money from that while then
also then teaching that and scaling it
into this
dream of being able to package promote
and profit from what you know
through being a youtube content creator
so good and you just actually touched on
the
first way that you were able to go full
time right you were able to
not have to have freelance clients not
that you couldn't have right but the
idea of
really making that pivot into using one
revenue stream beyond just freelancing
or your day job or whatever that looked
like for you
which was number three affiliate
marketing
yeah so we number one talked about first
of all
you want to um focus your
day job to find your dream job number
two you start your side hustle start
your own business i started clear vision
media
and then number three affiliate
marketing and here's when i learned
about affiliate marketing this was my
story of why it got so exciting
i was like okay i'm gonna buy cameras
that are very expensive and lenses and
rigs
like in sliders and tripods and gimbals
for my video production company but wait
a minute i could then
also like if you will in my free time in
my extra time i gotta go do the client
work
and i'm still waiting tables at red
robin but on the weekend i could shoot a
video
reviewing this camera that i invested in
and earn another stream of revenue off
of it
and this started to kind of expand my
thinking today i can't not think about
affiliate
marketing i still have my sean cannell
channel where
i don't get to it we're very busy here
and maybe that's just an excuse and i
need you to call me out
uh but i want to talk about whenever i
buy something when i think about like a
massage gun
which i use for running and these impact
guns from like theragun
i'm like this is an affiliate video so
it's not only on money that you spend
i think about like i think his name seth
james is a running youtuber
every running shoe he invests in he
talks about and links to it as an
affiliate
so you actually can start monetizing off
your hobby or monetizing off the things
that you use in your business
and to go back the best way to do this
is to master the topic do the thing
let's say you're a photographer you're
doing wedding photography
but then when you teach the thing
helping other photographers
they want to buy the same lenses as you
or learn about the lenses they want to
buy the same lightroom software
that you might be able to you know have
the luts you use
so affiliate marketing let's define what
it is it's a cool way of getting
paid from recommending the products
you love and you use so i started to
experiment with this
the first thing because of knowing that
youtube is a search engine
and actually not you know go back to
part one where we talk about claim and
master your topic
i didn't really see video at first i
kind of was more off the
just wanting to be a personality or a
vlogger but what i did on my personal
channel was i started this gift ideas
for him
series and i put out a video called gift
ideas for for him it's almost a million
views to this day
it still ranks on the first page of
youtube
and i went around the house gathered up
like some beats by dre headphones
the four hour work week by tim ferriss
just a bunch of different books
my gps from our honda civic and i just
put it on i was like here's a bunch of
gift ideas for him but there's a bunch
of affiliate links in the description
um after i did the first video and it
did well and i started to earn 50 bucks
a month on amazon
i mean the first check i ever made was
two dollars and 12 cents so don't
despise small
beginnings but then i started making 100
bucks a month 250 bucks a month
500 during christmas and this was at a
time
where i still had my main job and a side
hustle
so now this became extra money my side
hustle was producing and affiliate
marketing was the vehicle
uh eventually i started doing best
camera for youtube on think media now
the numbers were rising
and the main affiliate program i was
focusing on was amazon especially
through gift ideas for him and
things like that and uh best camera for
youtube and the reason i liked amazon
was when you share an affiliate link
after you sign up for what's called the
amazon associate program
when you share an affiliate link and
someone clicks on it anything they
purchase
for 24 hours do you get credit for so
my gift ideas for him video came i was
like well wait a minute if someone
clicks this link
during the holidays when they're
shopping it won't even they might not
even buy anything i recommend
they're going to be shopping anyways
because black friday cyber monday all
these sales are happening
so that's why i started to earn side
income to the tune of some years a
thousand
extra dollars just from the amazon
associates program
because i put out strategic videos
around the holidays but i also did other
programs
mixbook.com um that's a photo book you
upload all your photos and they do
printed photo books or they do your
christmas cards
and i saw they had an affiliate program
here's this is tying your lifestyle
into your youtube channel into ways of
making money
sony and i always like to take christmas
photos creatively and i'm a photographer
so like
i would even just shoot our own set up
get our dogs dressed up so you know
get some sweaters shoot the photos and
then design our christmas cards and i'd
find an online site
and then i just was like well we could
just sit down and do a review of how we
did it this is the site we use
software is easy to upload here's the
photos here's the things
if you want to check out mixbook.com
there's a link in the description down
below
and then you that's another source of
revenue and we'd earn like 30
if someone bought their christmas cards
or bought a photo album
for their family from mixbook.com
eventually mixbook wanted to work for us
they started to give us
free christmas cards and they started to
give us just like a couple hundred bucks
and
that's what you know we won't even touch
it on that in this video but that's like
brand deals
even at a beginning stage and then
finally um
things like clickbank.com which is
oftentimes a lot of digital products
but i found a green juice product that i
i love called
organifi and heather this is what's
crazy
now all this money funnels into our
company think media but we just got a
clickbank check for 250 dollars
five years after i made a video
reviewing this
green juice powder that you can take
when traveling to stay healthy
this is all affiliate marketing and that
was that this is that third tip
there's other ways but i think that this
is the fastest this is the shortest path
to revenue you've got your base of your
day job you've got your side hustle
something a little more lucrative than
this then start building up affiliate
marketing
because that extra 100 bucks a month you
can start reinvesting that in your
youtube business
you start making an extra 500 a month
you start getting some extra money to
level up your gear
or to hire an editor or work with
someone like vid chops or whatever
and i think affiliate marketing you
don't have to create a course you don't
have to write a book
you don't have to create your own
product you get paid from recommending
another product
that ties into your niche that ties into
your topic that ties into whatever it is
you're helping
people with on youtube wow so much that
you just
unpacked there when it comes to
affiliate marketing a couple things that
i want to just
highlight that you said for the audience
you said don't
despise small beginnings you started at
two dollars
and 12 cents and most people would laugh
at that right most people would look at
that and say
okay fine so what's that going to do but
you saw that
as proof of concept and i just want to
encourage you think marketing that
if the affiliate marketing is something
you you
see as a big vision that could happen
for your company or for your youtube
channel
that don't despise the small beginnings
i love the next thing you said which was
wrapping the affiliate programs that
you're doing around your lifestyle
and your youtube channel the thing about
mixed books when i think about that and
the time in the season you guys were in
that was something you would have
normally paid for
that you then don't have to pay for and
not that you know they're throwing
millions of dollars at you
but not having to pay for christmas
cards one year could be an extra gift
for
a child in your family or not having to
or or the idea of getting that extra 200
from amazon from
referring people all year long that
that piece right there could be an
unlock to you being able to upgrade your
content or
your your gear so it's this idea of
wrapping it around the lifestyle that
you're doing again it's not like you
were doing
you know uh mixed books and then you
were doing um organifi and those things
on the think media channel that was
media and so one of the things you said
was
the idea of wrapping it around your
youtube channel you're not
you're not out there just recommending
anything and everything you're not
recommending
watches and running shoes and things
like that on
the main channel you're being very
strategic about what you are
recommending
because when you know your audience's
problems and ambitions
right we talked about the on the other
episode that when you know that their
problem
is how do i do x and you have the
solution with
someone else's product you get in on
that
cut that's a piece of what affiliate
marketing can do for you and i've got
the same experience in that for
affiliate marketing for me
you know i started my homeschool channel
and affiliate marketing has been able to
pay for ipads for our homeschool we've
been able to
get a um discounts or free product
because
of using uh our youtube channel around
that part of our lifestyle so i love
that that
is a piece of what you did now we've
gone through the first three
number four is going to be jv affiliate
marketing this is this is different than
say amazon
right because amazon does have specific
amounts that you can get
depending upon what category you're in
and there's probably
thousands of affiliate marketing
programs but this strategy specifically
the shortest path to income
i think can be very lucrative for
someone just starting out
100 and this is another this is actually
a couple nuggets in this episode for
sure
that we haven't talked a lot about and
jv affiliate marketing jv stands for
joint
venture and what this simply means is
where you would partner up with somebody
else
that is probably going to have an online
course maybe they have coaching
maybe they have an event or a virtual
event and
a jv partner a joint venture partner
gets a
cut when you recommend that typically
digital product
now i mentioned clickbank before and
organifi happen to be a physical product
green juice powder that they ship out
but the majority of clickbank.coms
products are a lot of stuff on marketing
on maybe
investing in stocks or things like that
but they've got like
how to prepare for a marathon how to
prepare for an iron man
um uh how to study the bible they've got
a lot of digital courses
and to break down what jv uh marketing
usually looks like
typically you will earn anywhere from 25
50 is very common and even up to 75
or more of an affiliate commission on
maybe something that costs as much as a
hundred dollars
so another one another tip for number
four would just also be to also say
potentially
higher ticket affiliate marketing
sometimes
if you promote someone's offer it
actually could be something like teeth
whitening or skin care
and sometimes if if someone purchases
the thing
and it costs 200 they give you almost
all 200 of that
potentially because if it's like a
dentist or some kind of company they
want that customer to then
hire for like teeth surgery later or
something so
so there's there's things you can look
into but related to jv affiliate
marketing when i started to learn about
this
a great example is my friend james
wedmore years ago
back when i'm trying to find the
shortest paths
to revenue so i can reach my dream of
going full time on youtube
he had a program called local video
academy now people are already following
me
for what's the best camera for how do i
get better at video
and he actually was teaching a method of
how to do video marketing for local
businesses
now again i was actually doing video
marketing for local businesses
i knew a lot of what was in this program
but i didn't have the time or
necessarily even the know-how
or the process it would have taken me to
actually create
this training program that he had to
help other people do this
so what do you do you partner up now how
do you sign up for one of these things
you maybe discover a person that has a
digital product
you see if they have an affiliate
program or a way to be a jv for them
and i usually go to the bottom of the
website and i signed up now local video
academy cost
2 000 because it was helping people
giving them basically a business so they
could go charge local businesses um
for doing video marketing for them and
helping them with again
all that kind of stuff and so i made a
video on my youtube channel about it
video did not do very well it's kind of
just a review or a promotion
of local video academy and it got
i think less than 2 000 views but there
was a couple different price points i
think if you
they had like some done with you it
might have been like 3 000 and then
there might have been one that was like
a thousand and the affiliate commission
though heather was
50 wow so when you talk about
on amazon i'm making 55 at the end of
the month or i'm making 350
at the end of the month or whatever
that's great and that's a little smaller
ticket
in this particular case i earned i want
to say is either a thousand or fifteen
hundred dollars
you want to talk about sony about fell
out of her chair my wife sonya is like
what do we talk
like because that's just fifteen hundred
dollars we made on the internet because
we got a
50 cut of i believe selling two units
of explaining what this program was they
clicked through and a couple people were
like
shoot i want to go through this
step-by-step thing these guys have
created so it might even potentially be
something you already do but you don't
have to take the time to make an online
course record the videos
make worksheets build the thing out
master the whole thing
so jv affiliate marketing could be of
something really powerful that you do
and since that time
we will partner with different people
when there's alignment when they've got
something that will let's say fill in a
skill set
um that we don't teach in our company or
somebody that we know
can help people reach their goals faster
we have one that we do with
my friend pete who teaches people to be
better speakers
heather you and i i'm sure could add a
lot of value to people to help them
improve their speaking
but we have not created the frameworks
and the process and while we have worked
on our speaking ourselves that's not our
zone of mastery
so what do we do we pass them along to
pete when he's got his online course or
his training
and oftentimes the affiliate commission
might be 30 might be 50
or 75 and as your email list grows and
as your influence grows
jv affiliate marketing jv marketing
can actually become some people's main
businesses they actually they go i'm
never going to create something myself
i'm going to kind of be
the guy that everyone looks to for what
is the best if you review the programs
or you know who's who
or you know you're just introducing
people to other
opportunities typically as digital
courses
and you can get very generous affiliate
commissions in the middle there and this
is actually why we started
um we don't really talk about this much
either but it's uh
vrapartner.com so people can become
uh jv's for our program video ranking
academy now
different people have different
standards like our standard is you
actually we want you to be a student
first
we want you to be you know someone who's
done video ranking academy
etc and if you jump there's i think a
form there to sign up or whatever but
vraypartner.com is something that we
offer our students and it's similar it's
just like i was an affiliate for local
video academy
there are there are affiliates now for
us that make
five six thousand dollars a month
because again
maybe they don't feel like they have the
skill set or even the desire or the time
right now
to go create an academy and build a
facebook group
and have support around it and have a
team with heather and melissa
and omar and tony and people support
like there's a lot that goes into it
so you go awesome all i have to do
potentially is
get traffic grow my youtube channel
build an email list help a particular
group of people and introduce them to
this product
and i actually could make some pretty
good money in the middle
yeah that was so rich with so much i
think we should do
maybe a separate episode on that at some
time because i'm sure there's going to
be interest
around this because it's kind of like
the unknown lucrative way
on the internet to not have to make
something and to be able to get
high commissions which is one of the
blockers that a lot of people have with
joining the amazon program or something
of that nature so
i want to do a quick review before we
get into number five and thank you so
much john for just being so generous
with the information you're sharing
today
we've got focus on your day job to fund
your dream job
start a side hustle then we have
affiliate marketing which was the third
way that you broke through and
was able to start making that third
revenue stream and diversify that income
and then the jv affiliate marketing i
love how you said that
you know when you when you do get that
first check for affiliate marketing and
you do get that first jv check
and you're seeing this money that just
came from the internet
i mean this didn't exist you know 10 15
20 years ago
so it's just such an eye-opening thing
to know that you can start with
two dollars and 12 cents and you could
be doing jv partnerships like you're
currently doing now
in the six figures that are happening it
definitely is a process and it's a
journey
but there is potential for those things
to happen number five though
it's probably one of my favorite ones
now uh because i've seen
the impact it can have on people is
youtube ads
so the fifth way of revenue to break
through for the shortest path
of revenue in your youtube business
would be
youtube ads yeah and you know youtube
ads is when you're able to
post videos on youtube and allow
advertisers to advertise on them the
video plays you can skip ad
you know there's banners below it and to
the side and to get this you need 1 000
subscribers 4 000
hours of watch time within the last 12
months and then you can start earning
money from youtube ads but here's the
crazy thing heather
is a lot of people giving advice we'll
mention this first and
a lot of people's ambition is like they
feel like this is what they want to
sprint for
they're like i gotta get my thousand
subscribers i gotta get my first
my four thousand hours of watch time
just so i can make two dollars
in the first month and 125 dollars in
the first year
you know even this is a great example
the think marketing podcast
we're coming into this as uh experts
we're coming into this with a million
subscribers on think media i've grown
multiple other channels
we're coming into this with a team and
and we've been building up this podcast
and we really hope
help it's hope it's been super valuable
and we are now earning on this channel
something like
550 a month in youtube ads
which is cool but if you want to talk
about sustaining the kind of thing
that's going behind this youtube channel
like that's that's like some serious
we're gonna be
homeless we're gonna be on the street
quick if that was the only source of
revenue
well there's a couple things it's a not
the only source of revenue
b we are funding it think marketing
is just we want you to think the same
way about your youtube channel
we're bootstrapping it our day job
happens to be think media
our side hustle happens to be think it's
investing in the next
thing and so youtube ads is too many
people's
first focus when here we're saying it
should be like your fifth
focus because first focus on your day
job second get a different side
income of money not even necessarily
related to youtube but
connected to your vision affiliate
marketing jv affiliate marketing
and then if you're posting consistent
content
and you're building up your views and
you're building up your subscriber base
you may hit a tipping point where
youtube ads start to become relevant
so an example is february 2012
on think media i earned something like
60 dollars that month in youtube ads so
now now it's getting like that's
groceries like that's a night out with
sonia like that's cool
now i also remember that month i earned
250 dollars from amazon affiliate
marketing so now we're talking
you know 310 february 2012 from those
two income sources
and again later that year promoting
local video academy
and then getting a check for fifteen
hundred dollars stacking it all up
stacking these streams of income up
but fast forward to today and think
media earns between twenty five thousand
and thirty five and thirty thousand
dollars a month
profit from youtube ads
and that's years later it's grown into a
whole nother thing this is no longer
just sean shooting videos in his bedroom
you know but youtube ads are something
that are almost like
my friend roberto blake says it's like a
tip jar like it should not be your main
focus think of it as the little bit
extra and if you look over there you
might be like
oh cool there's some money there or wow
like that's awesome or look what we can
do now
but it shouldn't be your main strategy
the first four tips i think is where
on this pillar principle claim and
master your topic
discover your audience's problems and
ambitions
begin putting out one video a week and
then find the shortest path
path to revenue focus on these first
four tips but then let youtube ads kind
of come in and eventually you can stack
them all
so eventually my story of going full
time
it officially happened october 2015 when
i got fired by all my freelance clients
in one month
three clients and i went all in on
youtube mind you
i went in all in on the foundation of
building up my channel for five years
before that
a little bit here a little bit there
really distracted
wish i had heather taurus in my life
because i was chasing 14 rabbits and we
tell people to just chase one
was not focused but i was chipping away
and i did have some momentum and some
money coming in and
and and some things happening and i went
full time
on youtube from just youtube ads
and affiliate marketing through amazon
reviewing tech
on think media yeah and when we take it
back to even the last episode where we
were talking about
you know if you already have a full-time
job if this is a side hustle and you're
gonna be putting in that five
hours a week hear me friend youtube is
the
only platform that pays you to be a
creator
so while you could be making reels while
you could be posting on linkedin or
posting on twitter
or trying to grow your influence on
these other channels
youtube is the one platform that pays
you to become a creator now
you have to put in work for that because
they want to make sure that the system
is working right
and i think that that shows credibility
i think that that helps you
you know put in the time so you can get
to that level but if you only have that
five hours and i love how you said you
know you started with sixty dollars
that can eventually grow into 25
you know 30 000. uh you know i just
watched a video
graham stefan who's on youtube he's a
real estate investor
talking about real estate on the
platform he's making almost a million
dollars now
on youtube ads why because he is
creating
he claim and mastered his topic he knows
his audience's problems and ambitions
he's creating not just one now but
multiple videos per week and now he's
combining all the revenue streams
and youtube is the only platform paying
him to do that i mean it's incredible to
think
that you're a small town kid right that
this was just a vision
but by being able to diversify your
income and being able to stack
upon each other right one brick and then
the next brick and then the next rick
you can create a business around your
passion you can really be able to
sustain this i i'm so enjoyed these
conversations where we've been able to
walk through
you know those four steps of getting
started on youtube creating we say a
high impact because
we want you to help people we want you
to be a part of your community we want
you to be of service to people
but at high income because we believe
you need money for the mission
you need to be able to sustain not just
yourself and your family
but we believe that you should be out
there
using your money for good and so having
money for the mission being able to
you know pivot from a day job into this
mind you
this is still a job for us we're not
like sitting around eating bon bons we
are
working to make this happen but it's
shifting into the idea where
you and i were sitting here before we
were recording and i said can you
believe this is our job like
we get to make fun content for creators
all day long
helping them with the lessons we've
learned in life and so i just really
want that for you think marketing and
i've been
uh so encouraged i've been encouraged by
being able to walk through this
uh these four steps with you and i can't
wait for the next
series well that was a
power packed episode with the five ways
to
start making revenue online on your
youtube channel
right now so many nuggets came out of
that one so i encourage you to
re-listen to this one if it went too
fast or if you're like me
and you love to really get all of the
good notes
out of an episode and if you want to go
deeper on youtube and you want to learn
the three secrets to success
on youtube sean cannell is also sharing
with you
a free youtube class this is a brand new
and updated class for you
to take you can go to
tubemasterclass.com and register for
that class
it's a full one hour class where sean
breaks down his three secrets to success
on youtube and really dives into how do
you make this sustainable how do you
make this work for you
in any niche and at the end of that he
shares with you the opportunity to go
deeper with us
here at think so you can register for
that free class today
at tubemasterclass.com and
here on the podcast we love to see you
rate and review
the podcast over on apple itunes it's
amazing to be able to read your comments
all about how this podcast is helping
you grow your influence online and
today's
shout out goes to elsa she said i love
it sean heather and the guests they
bring are extremely detailed and honest
definitely guide you through the world
of youtube while giving you
ideas to create and grow your business
outside of youtube
must be adaptable social media is always
changing and i enjoy
learning and cannot wait to continue
joining growing my channel
i am so grateful for you elsa for being
a part of this community for
sharing that on apple itunes and for
letting us know that these episodes are
bringing you value
and helping you grow your channel this
is the last episode of this four part
series so if you didn't
have time or you haven't yet listened to
the other three
i want to really encourage you to go
back and listen to those three so you
can get
all four pillars of how to build that
high
impact and high profitable channel on
youtube next week we're heading into a
brand new series and i can't wait for
you to hear it we'll catch you
next tuesday
you